an alarming amount of items in the
supermarket's
sold as reduced-fat or healthy options
are actually concealing unbelievable
amounts of hidden calories [ __ ] sugars
and salt here's some of the worst
so-called healthy food prepared salads
salads surely not many people paid
salaries sold in the supermarkets and
restaurants actually contain more
calories than a Big Mac salad leaves
vegetables and fruits are incredibly
good for you
but it's the mayonnaise salad dressings
and artificial flavorings that pile on
the pounds
an average shop bought chicken salad
with dressing contains 730 calories 48
grams of fat and 1218 milligrams of
sodium 1/2 healthy salad make your own
and drizzle a bit of rapeseed oil and
lemon juice over it reduced fat peanut
butter believe it or not you're much
better off eating normal peanut butter
than the reduced fat variety
reduced fat peanut butter and regular
peanut butter contain exactly the same
amount of calories however reduced fat
peanut butter contains a shedload of
added sugar to supplement the reduced
fat sugar is much worse for you than
natural peanut fats to produce reduced
fat peanut butter the peanuts are
stripped of all their natural oils sure
peanut oils are fussy but they contain
good monounsaturated fats which actually
have many health benefits such as
reduced cholesterol levels lower risk of
heart disease and general weight loss
remove the fats and you remove all the
peanut butters health benefits granola
granola is a perfect example of bad food
hiding in healthy clothing you have to
ask yourself how can something which
tastes so good be healthy granola is
typically made with large amounts of
added
and fatty oils however Oh are naturally
good for you and there are healthy
brands of granola without added sugar so
check the ingredients before you buy
vitamin water unflavored water
vitamin water may seem innocent on the
surface but it's basically hyped up
sugared water a bottle of glace vitamin
water contains 8 teaspoons of sugar
cleverly disguised on the label as
crystalline fructose which is basically
a form of sugar
it also contains excessive amount of
citric acid which can be unhealthy in
large quantities and causes erosion of
the teeth 1-2 vitamin water that's
really good for you squeeze a lemon into
a glass of water
lemons contain all the vitamins a
vitamin water without the added sugar
energy bars and cereal bars energy bars
are packed full of sugar some energy
bars actually contain more sugar than a
can of cola and others are almost 1/3
fat sure energy bars will provide you
with quick energy because that's what
sugar does but it will wear off very
quickly and leave you feeling even more
lethargic than you did before
guess what your body can only use so
much sugar at once the rest of it is
turned into fatty acids which are stored
inside your body piling on the pounds
when you eat an energy bar that's
exactly what happens to the majority of
the sugars multigrain foods don't
mistake multi-grade for whole grain
there's a very distinct difference
whole-grain means the food contains all
parts of the grain whereas multigrain
means the food contains different types
of grain although none of them has to be
whole grain whole grain foods are packed
full of healthy nutrients and fiber
whereas multigrain foods don't
necessarily contain any healthy grains
whatsoever movies in small amounts pure
fruits movies are very good for you but
many contain large amounts of added
sugar ice cream
even pure folks movies are bad for you
in large amounts
first contains lots of natural sugars
which are much better for you than
refined sugar but even natural fruit
sugars will put weight on you if you eat
enough of them some smoothie served it
smoothie bars clock in at over 500
calories however smoothies contain
numerous health benefits because of all
the beneficial vitamins and minerals in
fruit make your own smoothies using pure
fruit and water and stick to one small
glass a day to keep the weight off while
soaking up all the benefits but free and
zero calories fat free versions of foods
may seem great at first glance but
you're actually better off eating the
full fat variant don't mistake fat free
for calorie free fat free food often
contain more calories than regular foods
when you remove the fat from food you
also remove most of the taste so to
counter that food manufacturers replace
fat with sugars sweeteners thickeners
and salt these can all be much worse for
you than fat you see it's not fat that's
the problem it's the type of fat there
are two types of unhealthy fats
saturated fat and trans fats
similarly there are two types of healthy
fats monounsaturated fats and
polyunsaturated fats fat free foods are
stripped of any healthy fats that they
may have had and replaced with unhealthy
sugars and salts diet sodas studies at
the University of Texas Health Science
Center have shown that the more diet
soda a person drinks the greater their
chance of becoming overweight diet sodas
are packed full of artificial sweeteners
which disrupt the body's natural ability
to control calorie intake the most
commonly used sweeteners are aspartamay
cyclamate saturon acyl famke and
sucralose the list of negative affects
afflictive form artificial sweetness is
endless
it has been strongly linked to
depression individuals who drink diet
soda are 30% more likely to be diagnosed
with depression in their lifetimes
artificial sweeteners greatly increase
the risk of preterm delivery amongst
pregnant women but scariest of all
regular consumption of diet soda
increases your risk of type 2 diabetes
by 67% so next time you have a sugar
craving you're much better off
satisfying it with regular full-fat soda
the same applies to tea and coffee it's
actually better for you to sweeten your
drinks with sugar than artificial
sweeteners sushi most sushi is made with
white rice but contains very small
amounts of the good stuff
aka fish white rice is high glycemic
food high glycemic foods promote a rapid
increase in blood sugar and insulin
levels which is followed by a very rapid
drop in growth this leads to a greatly
increased appetite which makes you crave
junk food while sushi is not the Sun
healthy in the direct sense it can
easily lead to overeating
however some sushis do contain copious
amount of added salt dried fruit surely
dried fruit is good for you after all it
just fruit think again
fruit is mostly water remove the water
and you're left with pure sugar this
small amount of sugar isn't so bad when
you consume whole fruit but when you eat
dried fruits you're eating a lot more
sugar per portion just a small handful
of raisins contains 22 grams of sugar
thanks for watching until next time